you
it's a little terrifying to be sitting
next to Edward Norton who I know best is
a neo-nazi or a schizophrenic domestic
terrorist or a guy who turns green and
an enormous when angered but he's here
in a different role today as one of the
founders of Crowdrise which is using the
power of social networks to raise funds
for philanthropies and nonprofits that
that most need the money so I'm really
excited to talk to you about it I'll try
not to make you angry just thanks so
let's start by talking about how
Crowdrise
works cuz it's really fascinating
concept if I just a regular guy want to
see what happens in Haiti for instance
and I want to raise money for Haiti how
would I use Crowdrise to make that
happen well I think that I think the
important thing to understand is that
we've designed this with with different
kind of contextual frameworks in mind I
mean in the sense that an individual may
want to in a self-starting way have a
robust platform or a tool or a utility
for just just in a self-motivated way
backing a cause that they care about
without any interaction with the
organization itself the or on the other
hand an organization may want a more
cutting-edge way of reaching out and
creating crowdsource fundraising
movements what we've got up here is hope
for Haiti this is really interesting
because this is a case of an
organization that didn't in it contact
us in any way this is kind of our model
of how easy it is for an organization to
use they they set this up without ever
even connecting with us directly and and
and created a very creative campaign in
which basically they asked their
existing supporters to fundraise for
them and offered a trip to Haiti to the
list of people who hit a certain
benchmark so they took sort of they took
the assets of their organization in
in the sense that experience of going to
Haiti was an asset and we helped them we
helped show them how to leverage that
into an exciting incentivized campaign
so this is going to they're people who
are already committed to their cause and
sort of saying raise as much money as
you can for us from you all right
however you can do it in the
organizational context one of the things
we think that there's a lot of a lot of
evidence of is that is that what a lot
of these crowdsourcing tools offer is
the chance to to create multiples and
leverage through your existing base of
support in other words you you know we
don't we don't obviously want to gum up
the works between an organization and
the people who already support them but
the people who already support an
organization are more than just donors
they are a 21st century network for
fundraising and and they can often reach
out and raise significant multiples of
what they're able to donate themselves
so those people would for instance put a
post on Facebook or something and say
you know check out my Crowdrise page yes
there are ways we've designed it to be
able to interact well with Facebook and
Twitter and other social connectivity
but you don't actually need those and
Crowdrise itself it makes it very easy
for you to just message directly to your
contact list right I you know you talk
about it reminds me a little bit of the
Obama campaign you know back in 8 you
know they had this sort of point system
which you guys have as well which we'll
get into later and it was very much
about putting challenges out there for
people to meet yeah and I think and I
think was a very significant
demonstration that affected a lot of us
who were interested in these kinds of
movement potentials in the sense that he
did that I mean a lot of people talked
about how Obama got you know almost 70
million discreet donors and how many of
them were under $100 but I actually
thought what was less focused on and was
to me even even more eye-opening was the
success that that campaign had
at just what we've talked about saying
if you can donate $25 fantastic but if
you can raise 250 dollars even better
and lots of people did that Lots they
got an incredible conversion rate on
getting especially young people who had
limited capacity of their own to go out
and create for them multiples just
through their passion and their interest
and so this is a site for organizations
to tap into some of that same yes and
also for individuals maybe without as
you were saying without the involvement
of the organizations yeah a great
example we had a 12 year old girl who
wanted to volunteer in hospitals she
wants to be a doctor she she couldn't
she was too young and she read about she
read on her own about a floating
Hospital on Lake Tanganyika that goes
around and services people in very poor
communities she went on Crowdrise on her
own set up that organization as the
beneficiary of her project and raised
she maybe up to like $4,000 now I'm not
sure she was 13 years old and she did it
by by by really creatively and
intelligently messaging to her own
network and I think what he or she is
Julia yeah we owe 8,000 I'm sorry I had
I gave her half the credit she served
she's 13 years old she's rates eight
thousand three hundred dollars for an
organization that had in no way had any
prior contact with her so so I think you
know this is a incredible demonstration
of the capacity of a very young person
who's conversant with these tools with
this kind of communicating to go out and
do something very significant now we
just saw a presentation from Nancy
Strickler from Kickstarter who you know
we showing some of the videos that
people have posted and some of the ways
that that people have gone out to try to
raise funds for their projects are you
seeing similar kind of creative efforts
absolutely yeah we've I mean everything
from Will Ferrell creating a Sun Tan
Lotion with himself naked on it that you
get if you donate to his through his
face too we've seen it cost more from
not associate it we've seen you know a
woman who is set up she she hasn't
launched her campaign yet but we've seen
that she's set up that she's going to
water ski around Manhattan
and she was to benefit medical care for
Iraq veterans well you know and I think
I think we not unlike Kickstarter I
think Crowdrise has a very robust
capability of supporting a lot of
creativity in terms of the way you
envision your own fundraising and and we
think importantly a lot of fun we think
it needs to be fun it's very very
important that that this that a new
generation of people starts to connect
with this kind of activity as something
that's that's that's not not cool that's
too easy a word but but fun life
expanding pulls on their skills their
creativity creates new connections and
friendships you know one of one of my
favorite stories in our first you know
nine months of operating this site was
that because of the point system which
you talked about and people who were
building a lot of points on Crowdrise we
should we should just explain that yeah
yeah this is like a Foursquare kind of
thing where people can yeah we we
created a virtual point system that as
as people take actions raise money
create new projects they get different
points they can award each other points
for cool projects it's all completely
virtual but as and you can they start to
get titles as they as they mount through
the point system but people following
each other's points it tends to make
people check out each other's projects
and in one case we had two women one in
the UK and one in the United States who
like because they were competing with
each other on points they looked at each
other's projects one got involved with
the others and they became such good
friends that they've now both gotten a
Crowdrise tattoo on their ankle which we
thought was a we thought was a
significant demonstration of our of our
user loyalty so it was a big moment when
yeah first tattoo yes yeah so you know
over the last couple of years in the
wake of everything that's having the
Middle East the Green Revolution all of
these things there's been a lot of talk
about you know there's New Yorker story
a famous New Yorker story by Malcolm
Gladwell about you know how deep our
social networks really you know
Gladwell's argument was that it favors a
sort of superficial kind of connection
that does not result in you know deep
sustained involvement and I you know
it's easy enough to push a button and
donate money but how do you turn that
into a real relationship and something
that's deeper well I I mean I have a
couple of problems with that for one I
think it's it's very premature I think
that we were talking about it backstage
you know I'm a connecting it to Wired
which I'm a fan of I really like Kevin
Kelley's books out of control and what
technology wants I think I think
articulated some really fantastic things
about technological phenomenon and the
idea of emergence theory and how
difficult it is to predict what the
actual emergent phenomenon is going to
be in the very moment right before it
happens and I think that what we've
watched already with social networking
to a certain degree is that is that each
time the cognoscenti kind of sort of try
to pin down what the limits of its
potential are they're proved wrong in
the next five minutes whether whether in
terms of scale of users valuation as a
company profitability or I think too in
assessing too quickly what what are the
impacts of these things because there's
they're maturing and evolving at such an
incredible rate that that I think it's I
think it's foolish to to try to it's
presumptuous to make that assessment
right now and I think already there's a
lot of evidence that flies in the face
of that I would I would flip back to
someone like the girl Julia there's a 13
year old girl who is using the kind of
the game theory of social networking
that she's obviously already grown up in
to achieve something that's the
definition of substantive she's
identified something happening in the
world that she wants to engage with has
no money to give on her own and has
raised such a substantial amount of
money that the organization is reaching
back out to her to cultivate this child
as a potent supporter of what they do if
that's not a substantive relationship at
being formed then I don't know what is
and I think that that you know people
have a tendency to focus on the fact
that Facebook and Twitter which are in
essence
at their core social narratives you know
those are platforms for personal
identity narrative Facebook is this is
what this is my life as defined by who
my friends are
Twitter's this is my life as defined by
what I'm doing right now but I think
that as these that this will continue to
mature and differentiate a new niche
platforms in social networking will form
which is what we we thought a lot about
this with Crowdrise because we didn't
want it to be what we called sort of use
and drop utility we wanted it to be a
personal narrative platform where you
anchor your life you act you anchor your
activist life and I think that the you
know we wanted to add to the chain with
Facebook Twitter these things so that so
that you have a Facebook page that you
socialize on but you have a Crowdrise
page because this is where in a
long-term sense you do you you affect
the world and instead of doing it and
then it going away it maintains this
long-term aggregating narrative of what
you've done so that you can see your
impact growing oh right right so where
Facebook builds a narrative around who
your friends are and Twitter builds a
narrative around what you're doing
Crowdrise builds a narrative around what
you can't you care about absolutely this
is my life as defined by how I'm trying
to change the world that's now we talked
a little bit about this backstage as
well you know traditionally the way a
lot of nonprofits and charities have
worked is by identifying the highest
value donors and going after those guys
yeah this raises the possibility of
again in a sort of Obama s turn opening
that network up to millions of smaller
donors yeah but what how does that
change the way an organization runs how
does that change this or what's the
impact of that well I think that um you
know macro philanthropies never gonna go
away
especially as we see increasing wealth
stratification you're gonna have more
and more of the Gates Foundation here
you know big donors is a great thing and
it's never going to go away I think
there's this emergent phenomenon of
crowdsource fundraising gret there's
always been grassroots fundraising and
organizations have always tried to
figure out how to create grassroots
bases but I think that what this has the
potential to do is drag
Stickley reduce the inefficiency of
other forms of fundraising we all know
anyone involved with organizations knows
that fundraising is terribly inefficient
that's the dirty secret of it is that
most of these organizations are spending
between 20 and 40 percent development
costs or you know or you go to a rubber
chicken dinner and you know Cheryl crow
plays and you give your money and they
say we raised a million dollars tonight
they didn't they spent five hundred
thousand dollars to mount that event
it's a horrendously inefficient way to
raise money crowdsource fundraising is
generally coming in at under 8%
costs and the truth is that it's more
often paid by the donor and not the the
organization's so in the argument can be
made that this is zero cost basis
fundraising and I think that I don't
think I know I don't think they're
mutually exclusive or that I think
they're very complementary in the sense
that if you look at things like we ran a
campaign with the Red Cross they got a
they got a macro philanthropist grant
for the Japan Relief this family the
Ogawa family gave $500,000 as a match
campaign and the Red Cross came to us
and said you know we assume we'll make
this match mostly through large checks
but we'd love to do some of it crowd
sourced and we raised over 50% of the
match through small donations in less
than three weeks so that again the
capacity of of creative forms of
crowdsource fundraising to leverage
macro philanthropy and actually create
connectivity between the people with
that kind of capacity and other people
who want to be involved is really strong
I think it's amazing I you know I feel
like we could talk about this for as
quickly as we're talking you know so
much more to talk about we're running a
little long but I do want to make an
announcement that that last night wired
started a campaign on Crowdrise we're
donating money to the to Khan Academy I
don't know our people here familiar with
Khan Academy Sal Khan it's a series of
online educational videos that really
amazing they're kind of revolutionising
education this is an incentivized
campaign so anyone who donates $34
we hope you'll donate more anyone
watching out there but anyone who did
anyone who does give $34 is entered into
a contest to win and i chat with right
edward north
good exam and it's great you guys are
doing this it's great we think that
there's enormous capacity for not just
organizations themselves you know there
are nonprofit organizations who are
often the beneficiaries but there are
also other communities corporate
organizations journalists or you know so
wired is a is like the community it's a
it's an entity and you guys have the
capacity I think to to expand and
redefine your own vision of corporate
Impact corporate social responsibility a
company and its reach into its community
and I think this is great you guys have
picked something organic to your own
kind of core mission and I think what we
were we launched it I think it's
actually going up 200 bucks since I
walked in the door but the but this is a
good example because for instance the
first thing we threw in there of winning
the I chat with me a that's just one of
things will work with wired on you know
wired obviously you know a year's
subscription to Wired for anyone who do
you know enter 18 bucks in the next 18
hours and you'll be entered to win a two
year subscription to Wired you know what
I mean anyway you can take the assets
you know think goes about 18 bucks yeah
lunch with Kevin Kelly you know what I
mean I mean what however there are so
many things that you guys can can offer
in a way to incentivize your core
readership to get engaged in a fun way
and it's cause that you support and I
think we'll have really great success
with this that's great and but I should
say that anyone who doesn't know about
Khan Academy should check out the August
issue of Wired it's coming out about a
month so Edward this was really great
thank you so much for your time that's
not thanks a lot ofstuff
yeah thanks